c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche et embarque à la télé a été
une avancée s'est arc s est de plus en
plus dark ac c'est maintenant c'est à
mourir de rire ou à pleurer de rire ça
dépend dans quel état d'esprit ça a du
mal à se sa du mal à supporter les
années trop c'est ça et terrasses ramé
ces nouveaux data a l'air de bien avoir
remonté la pente elle est de retour ce
traitement en poils sous les serres à sa
cause est vrai que ça procure du mois
à la longue ça diarra sera alors c'est
d'un cadre en sport c'est extraordinaire
de scor
c'est le sport c'est ce qui vous apprend
la zone essentielle dans la vie ça vous
apprend à perdre c'est au début c'est
d'arca et à la fin c'est rare de voir ça
peut être méga darga quand tu te fais
prendre tout on osait tnt a raté en
d'arcade ou
[Musique]